Rumor Willis is officially a mom making
Bruce Willis and Demi Moore first-time
grandparents honestly this is so crazy
I'm so excited rumor welcomed her first
child with boyfriend Derek Richard
Thomas it's so beautiful it's unclear
when the new parents started dating but
last November they made their Instagram
debut and a month later rumors shared
news the couple was expecting in a
series of snaps the mom-to-be showed off
her growing belly it's such a cool
exciting thing and documented her bump
Journey along the way I tried it was
hard seems Life The Sweep between the
lovebirds back in February rumor raved
over her man as they celebrated
Valentine's Day writing in a lengthy
post I didn't know that love could feel
like this I've never been so happy in my
life she goes on saying she admires his
fun and Goofy personality admitting it's
what made her fall in love with it I
feel like it's one of those things where
you know that it's going to be so great
plus rumored thanks Derek for making her
a mama and being her partner in their
wild ride into Parenthood I'm just
really excited to kind of see what's
next
rumors always remain tight-knit with her
family we have text chains
chain myself
officers that are are hilarious that you
know they bring me so much joy remember
what it really is just to be a family
and and you know families are there for
each other in the UPS downs and The Good
the Bad and um really just making sure
you make time for each other this Rings
especially true since they announced
Bruce would be stepping away from acting
last year after his Aphasia and dementia
diagnosis his current wife Emma X Demi
and all five children have continued
sharing updates on his condition
[Applause]
[Music]
and that family bonds is something rumor
essential always treasure I have such a
great foundation and such a great family
because no matter what crazy Endeavors I
decide to go after even if you know
they're nervous or they might not know
what I'm thinking when I'm deciding to
do it they are always
behind me and supportive and I think
that's such a beautiful gift to have
when you know you see a lot of families
especially in Hollywood grow very
distant from each other
foreign